this video is sponsored by Skillshare
the first 500 people to use the link in
the description and get their first two
months free earlier this month
China made history by becoming the first
country to land softly on the far side
of the Moon
what makes this mission especially
difficult is that unlike those on the
near side this one never has a direct
view of earth to communicate the rover
has to use a special relay satellite
positioned between them but for all that
extra work the Chung f4 gives China
international recognition it's not just
another landing among many and this is
just the beginning in 2017 France spent
two billion dollars on space Russia 3
billion the European Space Agency six
and China 11 and sure that's still far
less than NASA at almost 20 billion but
the u.s. also spends three times more on
health care for the same life expectancy
so money isn't everything
China is also opening up to private
space companies which quietly compete
with those in America like SpaceX and
Blue Origin space T for example
specializes in micro satellites weighing
as little as three pounds each a
previously unfilled but profitable niche
this rapid increase of Chinese
investment in space will generate
thousands of jobs and countless
scientific discoveries but it isn't just
about space it's also a calculated
military strategy with global
consequences 30,000 feet in the air
moving 800 kilometers per hour you can
watch this very video thanks to the 260
billion dollar-a-year industry that is
satellites with them we can predict the
weather snoop on our neighbors and of
course watch TV for free by the way if
you live in dish Texas which legally
changed its name in 2015 in
change for 200 free channels could be
worse but perhaps most important are the
31 satellites which form the global
positioning system cargo ships carrying
90% of the world's goods use it to
navigate precision farming makes plowing
planting and fertilizing vastly more
efficient pilots use it to fly
surveyors to measure boundaries and you
and I to get delivered the finest
Italian cuisine money can buy but
determining where you are is arguably
not even its most important function
it's also the world clock keeping the
time for everything from the New York
Stock Exchange to credit card
transactions and ATMs with an accuracy
of one billionth of a second it's no
exaggeration to call GPS one of the
foundations of the global economy so
what does it cost absolutely nothing if
you're an American taxpayer it's
included but for everyone else this 1.4
billion dollar a year service is
provided 100% free there's just one
catch GPS is owned and operated by the
United States Air Force like the
Internet it was originally developed by
and only for the military but in 1983
Korean Air flight
0:07 from Anchorage to Seoul made a very
costly navigation mistake instead of
flying a round restricted Soviet
airspace it unintentionally flew over
the Kamchatka Peninsula and on the same
day as a missile test at the same
location after tracking the aircraft for
over an hour it was shot down killing
all 269 people on board to prevent this
from happening again President Reagan
made GPS freely available for civilian
use and in 2000 President Clinton ended
selective availability granting everyone
not just the military access to the same
level of accuracy officially quote it is
not the intent of the u.s. to ever use
selective availability again which
notable
is not the same as we can't deny access
ever again during the war between India
and Pakistan in 1999 the u.s. refused to
give India access to GPS data much more
recently in 2012 a disabled GPS
satellite was blamed for a failed Russia
India missile test that uncertainty is
enough to make foreign countries nervous
and now consider that this hugely
important economy running technology can
be interrupted with a ten-dollar
spoofing device because GPS signals are
weak by the time they reach the ground
it's remarkably easy to emit a stronger
competing signal this device for example
can trick nearby cars into going the
wrong way or crashing into other
vehicles in 2008
Newark Airport became the first in
America to use the FAA x' next-gen gps
system for tracking planes which
frequently inexplicably stopped working
a three year investigation found a
trucker on the nearby New Jersey
Turnpike using a GPS jammer to stop his
employer from tracking him like the
drone which shut down the UK's second
busiest airport in December GPS jamming
is so dangerous because it costs so
little to do so much damage one single
drone 100,000 passengers and 760 flights
affected for all these reasons several
countries are launching their own
alternatives to GPS Russia has GLONASS
the EU has a Galileo and China bado
technically none of these systems are
directly competing 60% of receivers use
at least two of them simultaneously but
it's also in each country's interest to
control as much navigation as possible
it's also part of China's goal to secure
its claim to the South China Sea the
problem is just about everyone is
watching including the US which
routinely sends ships to patrol the
region in October one of
nearly collided with a Chinese destroyer
so the challenge for China is asserting
its claim without risking conflict
between two nuclear powers it's solution
are nicknamed the little blue men local
fishermen sponsored by the government to
work in the area and report foreign
activity to the military this way it
asserts its claim benefits economically
and does so in a less threatening way
but these fishermen have become a target
for nearby countries like Indonesia
which is where I'd ohcome Zin unlike GPS
China's version allows receivers to send
short messages and request military
assistance
it gives fishermen the full power of the
People's Liberation Army without
carrying a single weapon this is the
tension created by China's ambitions in
space whether it's purely motivated by
research and science or not doesn't
really matter either way it's going to
be interpreted aggressively by
established powers like the United
States space technology is at least for
now closely tied to the military it's
just one more way the world will have to
adapt to or risk escalation with the
meteoric rise of China investing in
space is about exploring the unknown for
the sake of discovering new things and
Skillshare offers that same kind of
feeling when you learn something new
like solving a rubik's cube taught by
the master of learning new things
youtuber Mike Boyd or let the amazing
Thomas Frank teach you how to be more
productive whatever you want to learn
investing design writing or animation
skill share has high-quality video
courses that will help you I'll take a
guess and say you enjoy watching youtube
videos so why not learn new skills from
those very same youtubers if you're one
of the first 500 people to sign up with
the link in the description you'll get
two free months of all the lessons you
could possibly want
thanks so much to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video and to you for
watch